[Applause]
[Music]
it's
bu
know I don't know why but I thinking
something to go
wrong but she looks in my eyes
and makes me realize
she don't worry baby wor everything will
be all
right don't worry baby don't worry
[Music]
baby I guess I should have kept my mouth
sh when I started to bre by my
[Music]
car but I can't back down now because I
push the other guys too
far what she does to
me when she makes love to me and she
said don't worry
baby everything will turn out all
right don't worry baby don't
wor don't worry
[Music]
babyc give it up for my
y'all
I have to say it we it was slick before
the stage and I was and I almost fell
one time so they made it sticky but it
was so sticky that when I tried to do a
little this my I was like I can't get my
left foot up anyway it probably looked
really awesome and I turned America on
with those moves um that was don't worry
baby in his Memoir Brian Wilson wrote
that he composed it after hearing the
Ronette song Be My Baby which is also
such a classic um he he heard that for
the first time and apparently he called
his lyricist right away and within an
hour of the words being written Brian
knew he had a hit did you hear it it's
still sticking it's I'm not going
anywhere okay like don't let her break
her leg um anyway I love that song so
much I love the beach Bo it's such a
good
[Music]
vibe
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home